metric packing problems and i want to
convince you
that using more or less one method
you can solve or you can try to solve
and you can get some good results on a
quite variety of geometric packing
problems so if i speak about geometric
packing problems you should think about
yeah different things kind of packing a
geometric figure into a container for
example
packing
a circle caps on on a sphere or packing
balls into euclidean space or packing
pentagons into the plane packing
tetrahedra into three space and so on
and so on and i want to show you one
method which is useful to study all of
these different packing problems
so to be more specific i want to give
you first definition what i mean by
geometric packing problem so it's going
to be um i want to study
a problem
kind of inspired by combinatory
optimization independent sets and graphs
but i want to do it in the geometric
setting
and i want to study independent sets in
candy graphs so they will correspond to
my geometric packing problems
so what is it so i want to look at the
calligraph a kd graph is a graph which
is defined by a group and by a subset
sigma of the group so it's going to be a
graph which is undirected where the
vertices are the elements of the group
and sigma determines the adjacency
relation so sigma
as i said should be
a subset of g should be close under
inversion and you should think about
sigma as being the neighborhood of the
neutral element
and then you have
and this neighborhood is transported by
the group action to all other groups
formerly it means that x is adjacent to
y whenever x to the y
inverse lies in sigma
and
because i want to have an undirected
graph i want to have that the set is
closed on the inversion
and
you also should note that
the caddy graph may contain
loops so this happens exactly when the
neutral element lies in in sigma
yeah it's a simple scaly graph you can
think of is this five cycle here so it's
a
five cycle so the group is that mod five
z and the generating set is one and four
yeah and i want to study this kind of
graphs and i want to study independent
sets in this graph so these are just
subset of the vertices subsets of of g
so that you don't have um adjacent pairs
inside of inside of i yeah so whenever
you have two points x and y lying in i
which are different they should not be
adjacent and they will correspond to
a valid packing
if you want to find good packing so
packings which have lots of elements so
the idea will be that we want to find
independent sets in the kd graph which
are as large as possible
but what i mean by large and this very
much depends on situation
so for example
in this case you can can simply count
the number of vertices so in this case
for example these two vertices from an
independent set
and then i can say well
2 divided by 5 is the density of the
independent sets which i have here
yeah but the notion of largeness very
much depends on on g
so what are examples
so examples i've given here three
examples
so the first example is a finite example
whether group g is the hamming cube f2
to the n
sigma
is
a hamming ball having ball of distance
of radius d minus one
so here it takes the hamming distance so
we find the hemmingball of course and
then what i do is i study error
correcting codes
if i want to find large independent
cells in this graph
so that's a finite graph something which
is a bit more complicated going to from
final to compact so infield graphs but
still to the compact graphs so this is a
graph
on
the special orthogonal group
so the group of all orthogonal matrices
having determinant equal to plus one
so what do we want to study here so what
do i want to do here is i look at the
circle cap on the units here
and this circle cap is transported by
the group action of the orthogonal group
and then sigma is made in such a way
that
if i look at circle caps which are
transported by the group then these
circle caps should not intersect
and this forms the neighborhoods of the
neutral element and this defines
at the end a picking problem on the unit
sphere by um packing by throwing caps
which is also called the circle code
problem
it's the compact case then the next step
is a locally compact case so here i have
son semi-direct product with rn which is
a euclidean motion group so here i can
translate and rotate things
so here i can translate and rotate my
rotate my objects and my object is a
convex body k
so here i want to pack convex body k
into euclidean space
where i allow that the convex body k can
be rotated and translated
here are the pictures corresponding to
the packing problems
so the first picture corresponds to
the second example i mean the first
example is not so interesting to draw
because it's only interesting if the
dimension is high enough
so i start with
the spherical chord problem so it's
packing storical caps on the unit sphere
and here i have three instances of the
third problem so here
my body k which i want to pack is the
units here so i do steer packings
and rotation is not so interesting
because
the body itself is rotationally
invariant
more interesting is
the
packing of pentagons in the plane
because here i can rotate and things
really make a difference
and then yeah getting things are getting
more and more difficult so here i have
tetrad packings in three space where i
also allowed to rotate things
so these are the geometric packing
problems i'm interested in and they all
fall into the framework of independent
sets in calligraphs
yeah so these are very old
problems there's a lot of history so
kind of to just to remind you piece of
history so it's part of hilbert 18's
problem to solve these problems
so he wants to yeah study building up
um up of space from congo and polyhedra
and then he asks how can one arrange
most densely in space an infinite
number of equal solids of given forms
for example spheres with given radii or
regular tetrahedra with given edges or
prescribed position that is how one can
find
one so fit them together that the ratio
of the fill to the unfilled space may be
as great as possible
in other words
part of 18 office 18's problem is to
study these geometric packing problems
and to
yeah and the solve goal of this talk
maybe a bit too ambitious but we all had
good lunch and so why why not so the
goal of this talk will be that we want
to solve hilbert's problem by computer
using some sos proof system
okay um
so this will not work of course in the
talk but i want to convince you at least
of a couple of things so the first thing
i want to convince you of that is that
at least there's so no theoretical
obstruction that this could work
i will show you that
if there is a proof
i mean you can always
you can find an sos proof
for
proving optimality of these structures
there is a proof
i don't i don't say how big or how large
a proof is and they don't say how
difficult it is to find but at least
there will be a proof so at least in
this sos proof systems
it's it's the ss proof systems are
strong enough to solve hilbert's
problems for arbitrary complex wallets
okay and that's the first thing i want
to convince you off and the second thing
i want to convince you of is that this
ss proof system also has some practical
meaning because i mean the ss proof
system will become as a hierarchy of
soft proofs and the first steps of the
hierarchy they give useful information
for the problem
so it makes sense to study these sof
proof systems so you get some hacking
from a low
rank sos
optimization
what do i just give i mean it's about
obstructions it's about upper bounds so
i want to prove upper bounds by this slf
processor
i don't know how to dualize it
but
i think if you go i mean this would be
an sos hierarchy
and if you go far enough in the
hierarchy at the end you also will have
a packing in your hand
so this also kind of gives you the lower
bound
but usually in practice lower bounds are
much easier to get i mean look it's a
kepler problem for example so upper
bounds are the challenge and the sos
proof systems give you upper bounds
so this gives you better and better
upper bounds
so it gives you better and better upper
bounds you feel better and better
exactly
since you mentioned it already so what
does this approach have to say about the
kettlebell um we come to that
i mean we don't solve it today but
it gives get some interesting insights
in the skier packing problem so there
would also be a way to describe it
without the kdcraft just as sort of on
the sphere but you you prefer the
kilogram formulation because it allows
you to do symmetry to this exactly i
mean i prefer the calligraph formulation
because at the end i want to do
computations and for this i prefer to
have a symmetry at my hand
and it's easier to kind of argue about
all the problems in one way
using the calligraph formulation
other than that i mean i just want to
speak
in one framework about all the problems
but other than that it doesn't buy you
anything
okay
okay so before i want to show you this i
mean
let's go back down to earth and see how
far we can get
and then you will see that we are not so
far
okay so i want to discuss the three
problems steel packings pentagon
packaging and tetra packings
um
so for for steer packings we know from
all these three problems
we have the best parts of history
problems but still the knowledge of
knowledge is rather limited i mean for
unit ball packings we know that it
solved dimension two because you have
the hexagonal structure and then it's
not too difficult to prove that it's
optimal it's much harder to prove
that this packing for example is optimal
to maintain three
this was first proved by hales in 1998
and seconds it was also proved by hales
in 2014
so he has two proofs
i mean one very difficult computer
assisted proof like 300 pages long
and then
he has another computer proof which even
computer can check now and
so if you're not convinced that
hale's proof was correct you should in
1998 but now i think you should be
really really convinced that it's
correct
um
so this is now dimension two and three
then there are two cases which almost
solved namely dimension eight and twenty
four
by cool and elkies in 2003
uh so in dimension eight and twenty four
things are very special because they
have very good sphere packing the minion
18 24. dimension eight the shear packing
comes from the e8 root lattice and in
dimension 24 it comes from the leech
letters
and colon er keys using a sum of square
proof could prove that this is optimal
up to a factor of
i think one dot one plus one to the
minus thirty so it's very very close to
the optimal and they contract so that
the sum of square proof even this
even can prove the optimality of
dimension 1824 but until now they
couldn't find the proof
yeah in lower dimensions
from four zone to nine here's the best
what we know there the situation is not
so good i mean lower bounds and upper
bounds are kind of far
apart um
so the lower bound coming from
constructions from special lattices are
here then the cool algae is bound the
sum of square bounds
is here and then together we start with
the last fernando oliveira we could
improve a little bit on the kune elki's
bound by using sum of squares plus some
extra tricks
but still you see
i mean things are pretty far
down at all the other
dimensions um
okay this was the good case now let's
go to the regular tetrahedra in three
space
so there was some race about good
constructions around 2010
and chen angle and lotze at the moment
have the best
construction for lower bound coming from
this kind of structure and they can show
that you can fill 85 percent of the
space by regular tetrahedra if you're
allowed to
rotate them
upper bounds are not so good at the
moment
because simply we don't have good method
at the moment for proving upper bounds
and upper bound by gravel else and
colors i think the 20 pages paper they
prove the upper bound of one minus ten
to the minus twenty six
so we show it's strictly less than one
but not so much more than that
okay but
it just shows you how limited our
knowledge is at the moment about this
kind of breaking problems
um so we wanted to work on this
and then we thought well before we do
the regular tetrahedra packings we
should go kind of do it the easier step
we also have similar features
and then we started the packing of
regular pentagons in the plane
and then there was a construction by
cooper beckham copperberg cooper back
sun and father
and this construction of two pentagons
it is also cooperback mother which also
does mathematics but she was not
involved at least not here in this paper
um
so there's a packing of pentagons having
two different
orientations and this gives you a
packing of 92 percent
and we could prove with our spectral
methods an upper bound
of
98
so also strictly less than one but
less than one than this bond
and the hope is that the methods which
we we use here are also useful for the
tetrad practice
yeah so
i asked many people in discrete geometry
i mean if they know any upper bounds for
this
but nobody could give me an answer so we
were probably the first one who kind of
really studied this problem
or kind of dare to say that we started
this problem
okay but
the methods we have
give this bound and this the hope is
that this bound will also transfer in
some way to the tetrahedra
other regular programs
is
something like this within
the bridge
then pentagons are the worst case and
otherwise
we don't know what when things becoming
round and round red then you can go to a
circle parking hexagon flying with
hexagons the extra ones you can pick
no no but so you know that that would be
even a nicer fear that for every k-gon
you cannot cover more than 98 of the
perfect
we didn't think about it but i think we
could prove that yeah yeah that sounds
like a nice
okay so that's the situation at the
moment so we are pretty far from
solving till about 18 problem even in
the plane
but still the methods because they're
uniform and they give the best known
results at least they're interesting
in some way and they're also interesting
for this workshop because they involve
some of squares and sdps
okay so how do
sos proof systems work
so here i give you the sas proof system
for finite graphs
so what do you do you formulate the
independent set number as a polynomial
optimization problem for example like
this
what you do is for every vertex
of the graph you have a variable the
variable should be non-negative it
should be either zero or one
and
you encode that you
should be zero one and if it's zero it
should not belong to the independent set
if it's one it should belong to the
independent set
and this is encoded by this quadratic
equation
and then you want to to maximize the sum
of x e squared so we want to have an
independent set as large as possible
so that's a polynomial optimization
problem you might think that this is a
redundant inequality that's true but
this is good for for us later for
for generalizing
uh this problem from final graphs to
infinite graphs
um yeah what do we do now yeah you can
set up the sos hierarchies to
approximate this
polynomial optimization problem
and when you do that
you get to the t step of last year's
hierarchy
there's a t level in the hierarchy
um so here i write it in the primal way
kind of using
pseudomoments
so here you should look at this
optimization problem the variable of the
optimization problem is y y is a moment
vector or pseudo-moment vector
y is indexed by independent sets i to t
of independent sets of size at most two
t
yeah y should be non-negative
then it should come
for a probability measure
so you want to have that y empty set is
equal to 1
and it should be pseudomoment this means
that if i plug
y
the entries of y into a moment matrix
then this moment matrix should be
positive 7.
so the moment matrix i've given you here
so the moment matrix of order t
um they're the inter indi
the entries are indexed
by the subsets
and then you have
its index jj prime we have y
of j union j prime
so it's a special matrix
where indices only depend on the union
of the
where the entries only depend on the
union of the of the indices
so this is this step of last year's
hierarchy
and then you can prove that in the first
step of lacie's hierarchy you're simply
dealing with
the lower season number of the graph or
with the strengthening by thriver theta
prime of g so that's the first step in
the hierarchy then you have a decreasing
sequence of upper bounds
which at the end in the alpha step
converges to the right number
so this gives you an ss proof system
for proving that
for finding the independence number of
a finite graph
and now the idea is that you want to
generalize this from finite graphs to
infinite graphs
okay
questions
we want to generalize it from final to
infinite graphs so the very first thing
we have to do is because we want to talk
about limits we have to
define kind of a topology on on the
complete situation
and before that maybe sorry step back
i want to say a bit
more about
the t-step because in the literature i
mean you see this is kind of the pure
t-step of the hierarchy but there many
variations possible
and
for example instead of looking at the
complete moment matrix you can look at
interesting sub matrices and so on
you can add some more attack constraints
maybe coming from extra inside of the
graph structure and so on and to
kind of speak about all these different
variations in
in one way i talk about endpoint bounds
and these endpoint bounds
are kind of parts of less hair's
hierarchy which make use of where of
pseudomoments
of order at most n
so this way
if you look at the t's hierarchy
then the t hierarchy is a two t-bond
so the first bound the first let's say
one of
of g is a
it's a two up two point bound
because we look at only at um moments of
order two
so
an endpoint bound is always weaker than
the
the
the end level hierarchy or
that more constrained so it could be
actually stronger than me usually
they're not comparable and this is just
kind of there's a zoo out
of different hierarchies and i want to
speak about this a little bit
and so they give give names to them
okay and now i want to generalize
these bonds to the infinite graphs
okay so we have to
need some topological assumptions
so the topological assumption i want to
use is that there will be some topology
on on the vertex set
and look at the calligraphs the
calligraphs they all come from some
topological group and there are some
natural topology on on the vertex size
and i want only the only thing i want to
have from the vertex set is that it's
the house of topological space
and then i want to connect the topology
on v to the adjacency relation in g
and the way i do this is i say that
every finite click
click in the graph is contained in a
clique which is an open set in the
deposit
so i think this takes a second to digest
but this is a very important kind of
definition which makes things work
for example think about
one single point one single point is a
clique
and this single point should be
contained in an open leak so there
should be a complete neighborhood of
this point which is in the peak
and this is of course true for all these
geometric packing problems because if i
pack some sphere here
then
the space around the sphere is
completely taken so i really have to go
far from this obviously
okay so that's a topological
restriction
and now here is a generalization so this
is a la says t step
for final graph and here is
the t step of last year's hierarchy for
this topological packing graph
so the only thing we are doing we
replace
the pseudo-moment vector y
by lambda
and lambda
now is not a vector indexed by
independent sets anymore it's a vector
which is a rail measure
on
the set item t
so from
moment
vectors we go to moment
measures doesn't sound so good but
that's how it is
um and then the other constraints are
very similar to the constraints which we
have here
so lambda of the empty set should be
equal to one
then out of lambda we can make a moment
matrix using the operator a t star i
will talk about this next on the next
slide this matrix should be positive
semi-definite
and
the objective function is
lambda of all
of all vertices of the graph
exactly
as here where it is the sum of all the
vertices of the graph of the of y
so it's completely
analogous except that we replace this
vector space here by the bored measures
and then we have some dual formulation
so we from measures to continuous
functions
so the dual formulation is is this one
here it's a minimization problem
that's the sos side of it
and yeah i don't want to talk about too
much about this dual formulation the
only thing i want to say that there is
no duality gap between these two
problems
for finite problems it's usually easy to
show here it's a bit harder to show that
there's no direct again
and for actual computations this dual
formulation is also important because
it is easier to solve these kind of
problems or at least it's easier to find
feasible solutions for these problems
and feasible solutions will give us
upper bounds for the independent cells
and here the operator a t
is defined as here and this operator
if we take the
the
the adjoint of this operator this gives
us a way to talk about moment matrices
on the measures
and then we can prove
a very similar to the finite graph case
that these s
this hierarchy converges in alpha steps
and the first step is something like the
theta theta number and then you have a
sequence
of numbers which converges alpha steps
to r
in the case when g is a compact
topological
so
it means that if we talk about
the compact case then this sos framework
is strong enough to
prove um
yeah to to
to solve all packing problems
in principle
but of course if you want to do
computations then only the very first
steps lesser one last two maybe less f3
are really computable at the moment
but nevertheless the framework is strong
enough to solve the problems
and if you talk about the non-compact
case like rn
then you can also use a theorem by
compactifying all right
so instead of working with rn you work
with a rn
modulo
some some big letters then you can apply
to this
torus you can apply the theory and then
you can let the
taurus grow
and you will solve the problem in the
limit at the end also in this case
what's that c
is it m
uh
let's see here yeah
okay
so here
in the dual formulation k are
the variables and they should lie in the
space and sees
the continuous functions
on
this direct product i t times i so c
stands for continuous and these are the
dual objects in the weak star topology
to the to the bottom measures
okay so that's the framework so in
principle we can solve hilbert 18's
problem by this
this framework
but yeah about explicit computations
we are not so far at the moment but
still we have some progress so here is
basically what is known for different
kinds of packing problems so packing
problems starting from binary codes
circle codes here packings and
convex
body packings
and two point balance the first step of
last year's hierarchy was computed by
del zard for binary codes by the dart
guitar title
for spherical codes code air keys for
steel packings
proving
almost optimality of e8 and leech
lattice and then we could generalize
this
together with fernando oliveira for for
convex bodies
the three-point bounds have been worked
out by thriver in 2005. so three-point
bound is some bound which lies somewhere
between la sale one and last year two
probably closer to last year one but
it's slightly stronger than last year
one
so is it like angle inequalities or
something like that it's stronger than
triangle inequalities
but they include strangle inequalities
so there is an extension of the salt
theory to symmetric spaces how these two
things
so that theory always talk about talks
about two point bounds
and then it's exactly the same
the only thing i mean
that that's theory for
symmetric spaces i mean it does says
that the optimization problem is going
to be a linear program
here i talk about scps
and
if the one bond is going to be an stp or
a linear program very much depends on
the structure of the space
so in this cases
for two point bounds this one this one
and that one there they're all linear
programs where this one is an s
this is not a symmetric space
symmetric spaces are exactly
characterized by this bones being lt
loss
okay so in circle codes
three point bounds were
worked out by by christine by shocker
myself
and then four point bounds
yeah this is kind of
the furthest people could go they were
worked out by heist right middleman
that's river a couple of years ago
and here all things missing
but of course this is i mean the the
table is structured in such a way that
if you go down things are getting more
complicated and if you go right things
are getting more
against this anti-diagonal structure
here
okay
now i want to say some things about how
to compute these bounds here two-point
balance
for the congruent copies of a convex
body
okay so here are general two-point
bounds for cali graphs
so that's the reason i focus on candy
graphs because then writing down lassie
one is going to be
a simple optimization problem
and the simple optimization problem
looks as follows
so we optimize
over
positive type functions
so we'll say in a minute what they are
so they're functions from g to r
which have some special
psd property
then these functions should be connected
somehow to the adjacency relations
so f of x should be non-positive
whenever x does not lie in sigma
and then we want to optimize this
fraction here
we want to minimize f of e f of the
neutral element
divided by
the integral over f over the complete
group the mu is a hard measure
yeah and what is um
what
is a neutral element
yeah and being positive type means that
a constructor matrix
and this matrix is positive
semi-different if the construction works
as follows i take
a finite number x1 up to xn elements
from the group
i
look at all the products x i x j to the
minus 1.
it's not going to be a matrix index by i
and j i plug in this
this product into f and this matrix
which i get should be positive similar
so you never label the edges of the
graph in a consistent way such that it's
positive similarly
and
they can do it for for all the x-rays
yeah this is i mean
if you don't work with scaly graphs then
you would have to optimize over matrices
or infinite matrices
indexed by the vertex set but here
instead of a two variable function it's
a one variable function so this buys you
a lot of
this saves a lot of computations
okay so what we have to do now is we
have to find out how this positive type
functions look like so we have to
it's easy to see that they form a cone
the convex cone and now we want to
parameterize this context
so we want to parameterize this count of
positive type functions and then we use
conic optimization to solve these
problems
okay and then we use some classics of
abstract harmonic analysis to to say how
these positive type functions look like
and they are very much connected to
unitary representations of the group
so how does it work i mean i can
construct a positive type function when
i have a unitary representation of the
group so pi is a unitary representation
from homomorphism from g to
the unitary group over some hilbert
space h pi
can we find a dimension can be infinite
dimensional can be one dimensional
okay and then we have a vector h lying
in the silver space
and then we construct a function f of x
as being the inner product of pi x h
with h and then it's easy to see that
this is a positive type function
very easy exercise
and takes one minute to solve
and galvan and rykov and 42 prove that
in fact all positive type functions you
can write down in this form
so all positive type functions come from
unitary representations
and the extreme rays of this kind of
positive type functions they correspond
exactly to the irreducible
representations
so if you want to optimize over this
cone of a positive type function then
it's good to
use the irreducible representation
and
yeah here's a kind of a very general
crm
which shows a complete characterization
of all positive type functions so it
gives you complete
explicit
formula for producing all of them using
all positive type functions so in a way
it is a generalization of the free
inversion formula of wagner theorem
for
and how does it work i mean it works for
for nice groups g and the groups i had
before or nice
then i want to have that f is also also
nice rapidly decreasing
and then it says that f is a positive
type if and only if i can write f as
this integral here
f as this integral and what do i do i
integrate over the dual group g hat
which consists out of all irreducible
representations
that takes a trace of some irreducible
representation by pi of x
times
f hat of phi
so f hat of pi these are the three for
the fourier transform of f at pi
some d nu of pi
and f is a positive i mean this works
this formula works first of all for
for all nice functions but f's of
positive type if and only if this fhat
is
a positive trace class operator
so in a sense this is the generalization
of a positive semi-definite matrix
and then if you want to optimize what
you have to do you have to have to
optimize over all these positive trace
class operators
f was a function on the group what does
it mean that it's rapidly decreasing
then you need some differential geometry
some v-group structure on the group
all these cases you can make very
explicit
i mean you need some extra structure and
an arbitrary group doesn't work but if
you have a legal group then you can you
can talk about
rapidly rapidly decreasing
um there are some more birds i mean if
it could happen that these things are
finite dimensional for example if the
group is compact
then
the h price are finite dimensional
and then you
and then the integral is um also an
infinite sum so it's kind of an easy
thing to do
but that can happen and it will also
happen that is h price are in the
dimensional object
so vectors notation g hat where all the
irreducible
unitary representation of the group
then
mu is the plotion measure
on the group and f hat is a fourier
transform of f
you can read of positive tightness by
looking at the fourier transform of f
and then if it's
positive and trace class then f is a
positive
what we have to do is we have to
optimize over all these f s
and this very much depends now on the
group how these effects look like and
how the h pi's look like
but this simply gives you
um a framework which works for
arbitrary nice groups
okay
so let's do this let's do this for the
case of the euclidean motion group in
the plane
so we have to find all irreducible
representations so these are given here
pi a are all irreducible representations
they're indexed by a by positive numbers
by the
and then
these reducer representations are really
infinite-dimensional so they map g to
the unitary group of
the space l2 s1 and l2 s1 is an infinite
space
so we really have to work with infinite
dimensional representations
in the representation you can write down
explicitly it looks like this so it has
a characters of rn
inside
and
if you work further you see
how the legal motor formula specializes
to this case
so you have your integrate over the dual
group the dual group is indexed by a so
you integrate from zero to infinity
then there's a long shelf l measure
which is ada times two pi
there's a trace of the representation
times f hat
and still f hat is optimization value
and we have to optimize over
f hat which are
trace class operators mapping l2 s1 to
l2
okay so that's the task
then
we can write down the basis of these
spaces
and then we can get everything kind of
concretely in terms of polar coordinates
and then f
of the in terms of polar coordinates
is written in this way
we write everything down into a basis
and the basis consists of
i some sines cosines and vessel
functions and so on
and then we have to optimize over this
infinite matrices f hat of a index by rs
good
so that's the task we want to optimize
over f hat ars
and we want to make it in such a way
that we have a positive type function
um
so we want to make sure that infinite
matrices index by r and s are positive
semi-definite for all a
what we did until now is we formulated
kind of solving the first step in the cs
hierarchy in terms of an infinite
dimensional stp
and now the next goal is we want to
reformulate it and we want to relax it a
bit to turn it into a finite dimensional
stp and then we want to solve this
rigorously rigorously on the computer
the good thing is that we work with a
dual formulation so it's enough to find
a feasible solution
finding an optimal solution i think is
rather impossible but finding a feasible
solution is is possible
okay and then we use again tools from
sum of squares
and polynomial optimization so what we
do is we make the following unders we
say that
o a free
fourier transform
is of the following form
like this so the form is that we have
basically a polynomial
depending on a times an exponential to
make it very rapidly decreasing and we
set a lot of this rs to zero
because we want to make things finite
and if we do do this and we set out to
the right
coefficients to zero then this forces
that this
function f is again a polynomial times
an exponential
and then we can use
tools from sum of squares to really make
sure that these polynomials which come
up are non-negative
and
okay so you don't have to worry about
the polynomial part anymore some of
square take care of this you have to
maybe one wonder where the exponential
part is but this is also not a problem
because the exponential part if you look
at this here is not negative anyhow so
it doesn't conflict with the point on
this
then you say that for example that these
these things here these polynomials are
sum of squares and then
if you enforce this
then you enforce that the function f is
of positive type
and this you can now formulate a system
a definite problem
so being a positive type function
you can
special
class of positive type functions you can
parameterize by
finite dimension
two steps of uh seven effect uh of ss
type relaxations first when you go from
independent set to the laser relaxation
and then
in order to get the
the certificate you
this again
yeah the first part is kind of uh
and this is just a trick to do some
things on the computer
the other one is kind of fundamental
first this is a relaxation the first
part is a trick to
something
okay maybe
so we have two tricks
after each other and what's the degree
of this atmosphere
uh we come to that to the degree we use
on a computer
okay so we can formulate now positive
tightness
but we also have to look at the
geometric condition we have to see that
these functions are non-positive
whenever you have x not lying and sigma
and if you translate this back now to
our geometric framework here
um
then
what do you have to do
we want to have that f x comma a is not
positive if x does not lie in k minus a
k it does if x does not guide the
mikovsky difference between
k and ak
and if a is fixed
think about the rotation a as being
fixed then k minus a k if k is a
polyethylene is just another polytope
and in the case of the five gone
then k minus ak
so this is say k the other five gone and
the other pentagon is
minus ak
then the mikowski difference is simply
this rectangle
so to fix
a we have
a polytope condition so we want to have
that the function is
non-positive outside of the molecule
and if we do the rotation now
then
we have a structure like this so it's a
twisted template and we want to have
that the function is non-positive
outside
and this you can also formulate as a
system condition
because you can say how these phases
look like and these phases are
parameterized by polling objects
okay then we can put everything into a
computer
and then it took us i think one year to
solve this problem
because there are many numerical issues
because first of all
the right choice of a polynomial basis
is very important
i mean if you just use a monomial basis
and things fail really bad
you don't get any results even for very
small degrees
for example for sphere packings if you
want to work with degrees say
six
then solvers don't work in this case
matrices of size six times six
well this cannot handle at the moment
and then after figuring
playing a lot with this bases we found
out that the right choice of our choice
was that we take
lager polynomials are
appropriately scaled
and this works well
and then we could
solve this
optimization problems using the software
sdp gmp
up to degree up to d
and 51
but the degree was actually twice of
twice this so we could work with
polynomials of degree hundred
and then to
make really rigorous computer proofs at
the end
because the sap gmp just gives us
floating point solutions so we really
have to make a
rational certificate out of it so what
do we do we do a lot of post-processing
so we take this
floating point number we perturb it to a
rational solution
that's not a solution anymore because it
will
either not be psd or it will not satisfy
all the equality constraints
then we analyze the quality loss of this
perturbation by looking at
eigenvalues and condition numbers
and then after we do this
we are at least sure that in the
neighborhood of this rational solution
which is not a solution there is a
solution
and for doing all this we had to write
some custom a c plus plus library
which works for stps with sos
constraints
okay so this is all the work we did for
the pentagons so how does it look for
tetrahedra
do you know for example it's this choice
of flabby polynomials is optimal in some
sense so
just a trick that works it's not so
surprising because these lager
polynomials also come up in the fourier
transforms
but we don't really have a reason at the
moment
are there some
failed polynomials that you'd like
for
i think work because we are dealing with
a non-compact domain
and the zeros of these lager polynomials
say go to infinity if the degrees don't
go to infinity and this is not true for
the other cases
um yeah tetrahedra
we're not there yet
so we think we need more automatization
also in the formulas on harmonic
analysis so we have to kind of find a
way to make these formulas correct
then we really have to find a way to do
numerical optimization in a stable way
so just
playing with lager polynomials and how
it works i think this will not work for
tetrahedra
the thing
is to the challenge
questions and comments for it
um
do you think that these methods might
generalize to packings in complex spaces
in public spaces complex spaces like i'm
interested in
packing lines in complex projective
space yeah sure people people also
worked this out
packing in productive spaces complex
productive spaces i mean there's a two
point bound and people work this out and
it's not too complicated
also three point bounds have been worked
out
by the same packings
for yes but if you want to do
computations you have to get
the fully analysis in it
you have to make things explicit
and it's a group if you don't have a
good group structure then things are
getting unique
so
like some of the
positive type functions etcetera all
exist
we didn't look at that
so is
you say that maybe in the fourth step of
less health however he could get the
optimal solution
i don't know
but i think it's very hard to compute
this
but you don't know an increase in the
obstruction
yeah and i think there's no principal
obstruction i mean if you go far enough
in the hierarchy you will
you will get
kept
i think
you first have to prove that the optimal
structure
will have some fire complexity
and i guess in three-dimensional space
you can do that
once you have that i think you can use
this machine
but i think then you also borrow a lot
of things out of here
good let's hang frank